This video is made possible by trends.
This is the ultimate knowledge hub from the hustle trends is a networking
community for entrepreneurs and budding entrepreneurs.
It's a place where you can connect and even workshop with investors and founders
who can share valuable insights to help get your ideas off the ground.
Trends brings together expert knowledge, data science,
and investigative journalism to track new industries and likely trends.
Remember our video about the surprising success of a two milk that outstrips
tech companies in profits in 2019? Well, over on trends,
you can find in-depth trend analysis on that. The alternative milk industry,
as well as detailed reports on loads of niche markets that could really help you
capitalize on your own ideas, or maybe have stuck for ideas, dive into trends,
exclusive research with intriguing topics to help inspire like the 30
companies defining the future of media and pop culture or data on thousands of
successful Kickstarter projects.
We also like the live weekly lectures from founders who give practical tips
about everything from internet security, to branding,
to getting the most out of YouTube. Hey,
you're never too old to learn something new, best of all rights.
Now you can get your first two weeks for just $1,
go to trends.co/visual politic for your $1 two week trial.
Now let's get into the video.
[Inaudible].
It is said that there are two challenges you should never enter into with a
Swiss national.
And the other is money
despite.
Having just over 8.5 million inhabitants and being nested amongst tranquil
mountains.
The Swiss Confederation with the GDP of over $700 billion has become not only
one of the richest countries in the world,
but also a safe Haven for the planets. Grateful. Yeah,
And I'm not just talking about money banks and financial investments.
It goes a lot further than that. For example,
Switzerland is also home to the largest art deposit in the world.
We are talking about a country where we can even find initiatives such as the
Brunick mega safe,
a project that involves drilling into the Alps to build huge secure volts where
all kinds of valuable objects can be stored.
But hold on in this video,
we are not going to focus so much on the Swiss economy,
but rather on a very odd institution that in recent years has become an
important player in the global financial market.
I'm referring to the Swiss national bank. Yes, that's right.
The central bank of Switzerland, a central bank.
So unusual that it's even listed on the stock exchange. Yes, yes,
that's correct. It is quoted as one more stock on the Swiss stock exchange.
In other words,
you could personally invest in the Swiss national bank and become a shareholder
of the central bank of Switzerland curious don't you think?
But that is by.
No means it's only peculiarity.
Did you know that the Swiss central bank has invested more than $170 billion in
shares of companies such as Apple, Amazon, Facebook,
or alphabet among many others?
Did you know that there are even.
Analysts and professionals who consider that the Swiss central bank has become
one of the largest hedge funds in the world and this new video that we have made
in collaboration with value school, we are going to give you all the details.
So let's get going a different kind of bank.
[Inaudible].
Friends of visual politics. Please pay attention to the following headlines.
Second 2020 Swiss national bank posts,
$50 billion profit on boost from Apple and Amazon and company windfall makes
Swiss central bank. One of the world's most successful investors in 2019
May 11th, 20,
20 Switzerland central bank bought up Apple GE and Disney stock.
It also loaded up on a marijuana stock.
Yes, I know it seems like news from a mutual fund or a hedge fund,
but we're talking about the Swiss central bank, an institution,
which like the European central bank and the Eurozone or the fed in the United
States has the main role of setting the monetary policy issuing the national
currency. In this case, this was Frank and managing the countries.
That is.
Usual task of central banks. However, as you can probably imagine,
the Swiss national bank has certain characteristics that make it quite different
from other central banks. First of all,
it is a bank that does not belong to the state and who share price is quoted on
the stock exchange. And that, how can I put it is far from usual.
A closer look shows us that the capital of this bank is made up of a hundred
thousand shares.
45% are held by the different cantons that make up this whisk Confederation.
Just.
A side note,
the cantons are kind of autonomous regions with a lot of self-government.
They set their own taxes that rules their regulations in practice.
They are almost small States that together form a kind of union,
the Swiss Confederation.
But.
Let's continue. So the various cantons share 45% of the central bank shares.
A further 15% is held by smaller local banks that also belong to the cantons
leaving the remaining 40% of float on the stock exchange.
In fact, the bank has been listed on the Swiss stock exchange since 1907.
So yes, without any problem,
you could become a shareholder of the Swiss central bank.
You can buy its shares just like you would buy those of any other company.
However, these stocks are a bit unusual.
Let's just say that the rights of shareholders are somewhat limited.
You see.
Ordinary shares of the Swiss national bank do not have voting rights in the
event of the banks liquidation,
the shareholders would only receive at most the nominal amount at which the
shares were issued 250 Swiss francs per, and what's more by law.
The shares can only pay a maximum dividend of 6% on the share capital,
which is 25 million Swiss francs. In other words,
shareholders can at best only receive 15 francs per share in dividends per
year. And so if we consider that the shares are currently quoted at 5,300 Swiss
francs, each that means that the dividend yield that shareholders receive,
which by the way,
is practically the only return they can get from this bank because the
accumulation of profits does not belong to them is 0.28% per year.
Yes.
Yes, 0.28% per year.
It certainly doesn't seem like the best investment in the world.
These shares behave more like a kind of very secure perpetual bond.
That is why the market value of this bank is only about
$600 million. But hold on a second.
Didn't we tell you at the beginning that this bank made a profit of $50 billion
in 2019.
Was all this money go accordingly.
To the national bank act,
which is the law that regulates the operation of this body.
These profits are accumulated in the bank's reserves,
which are gradually released both to the cantons and the federal budget itself.
90 20, for example,
the Kansans will receive 2 billion Swiss francs from the central bank and the
federal council that is the federal government will receive a fervor, 1 billion,
all in all, some $3.3 billion. And in other words,
in the case of the Swiss national bank business is not done by the shareholders,
but then what's the point why dedicate a whole video to the workings of this
bank, where all my friends,
because the Swiss national bank has another very special feature that has a lot
to do with the strength of the Swiss Franc and the country's economy.
So what is it? Let's take a look.
Everyone wants Swiss francs.
Swiss Franc is a very special currency, although it is a fiduciary currency,
virtually everyone trusts it.
This explains why this currency plays a very significant role in world finance.
Let's just say that every time there is an economic crisis or an international
financial crisis, the Swiss Franc becomes one of the most sought after havens.
When there are problems or trouble brewing,
everyone wants to have their money in Swiss francs in a way at the currency
level, it plays the same role as gold. For example,
after the financial crisis of 2008 demand for Swiss Frank sword,
this has also been the case with the coronavirus crisis.
And the question is why does the Swiss Franc play this role as an active refuge?
Why do investors feel more secure putting their fortunes into Swiss francs in
times of fear or stress? Well,
let's say that there are two explanations for this on the one hand,
the strength of the Swiss economy, which we'll talk about later.
And on the other hand, the historical performance of this currency
over the last five decades,
the Swiss Franc has almost doubled in value against the dollar and even more
against other major currencies, such as the Euro pound. And Ian, for example,
in August, 2000, the market was giving one eight,
three Swiss francs for every us dollar. At the time of making this video,
you would only get 0.9 francs for every dollar that's less than half.
Of course there is one problem with so much demand for the Swiss Franc.
If the currency appreciation is very rapid or abrupt,
the export industry may have problems and friends, believe it or not.
Switzerland is one of the countries with the most exports on the whole planet
each year, Switzerland exports, goods and services worth more than $400 billion.
I figure that accounts for more than 65% of its GDP,
which makes Switzerland a much bigger exporter than for example, Germany.
So what is the Swiss national bank doing to avoid very sharp reevaluations of
the Swiss Franc? Well,
to start with it tries to curb demand by setting the lowest interest rate in the
world. The official interest rate in Switzerland is negative 0.75%.
And since that is not enough, and people still want to buy more and more Franks.
Then its second measure is to expand the supply that is to issue many,
many new francs pay attention to this fact,
let's break it down since 2002,
the balance sheet of the Swiss central bank has increased almost eight fold.
In other words,
the central bank has increased the number of Swiss francs by hundreds and
hundreds of billions of dollars by the equivalent of just over
$850 billion. And in fact,
this explains why today its balance sheet is equivalent to 135% of the
country's GDP. This makes it in relative terms,
the central bank with the largest balance sheet in the world.
And.
Here friends is where we come to the key issue.
As we have seen the Swiss national bank is issuing new Franks to meet the huge
demand. That is,
it creates huge amounts of new Franks to be sold to investors in exchange for
dollars, euros, pounds, yen, et cetera, et cetera. And the question,
the big question is what on earth is the Swiss bank doing with that amount of
currency?
Listen up a national treasure.
Thanks to the enormous demand for Swiss francs.
The Swiss central bank has accumulated the equivalent of $950 billion in foreign
currency as of June, 2020.
And what do you think it has done with such an amount of money? Well,
it hasn't left it sitting idly. It has started to invest all over the world,
particularly in the United States.
Approximate.
Currently 90% of all foreign currency reserves have been invested as follows.
Most of it,
some 665 billion in debt from countries and large companies and the rest,
some $170 billion has been invested directly in shares. In other words,
the Swiss national bank has shares in the world's leading companies amounting to
some $20,000 per capita.
Impressive.
Give you an idea on August 5th, 2020, these were his three main positions.
What's the Swiss central bank has become something of a huge investment fund.
The best thing is that all these positions are financed with new Franks,
with the issue of new currency.
This is what is popularly known as printing bank notes,
who needs oil when you can have Swiss.
The fact is that.
Thanks to the huge international demand for Swiss bank notes,
the central bank is able to issue more and more Franks Franks,
which have ultimately financed the creation of an immense national treasure and
something that is even more surprising today.
The Swiss Franc is not only supported by the Swiss economy,
but also increasingly by this huge portfolio of investment in the best
performing companies.
Well.
Investments,
which as we saw at the beginning are already bringing enormous benefits to the
Swiss economy in 2019 alone, $50 billion.
It is a move and experiment that is unprecedented and has led many analysts and
academics to start to consider it a large hedge fund,
a hedge fund that sells Franks go short and Franks and buys goes long on shares
and debt securities. But at this point, the question is,
how far can the Swiss take this strategy? Let's take a look.
Sinus Swiss style.
In order for this whole game.
We've outlined to work with the demand for Swiss Franks needs to remain very
high. In other words,
for savers around the world to continue to see Switzerland as a safe place to
deposit their money here,
the competitiveness of the economy and the solvency of the public accounts are
key. The more investors trust,
the greater the demand for Swiss currency will be,
this will allow Switzerland's to continue to sell Franks and buy shares and debt
securities that generate a return.
What's a business printing paper selling it and having people buy it almost as
if it were ounces of gold.
No.
And you know what, at the moment it seems like the numbers are holding up.
Public debt is low. The government is financed at negative rates.
Their economy is doing reasonably well. They have practically full employment.
Their taxes are moderate. And on top of that, we can find new stories like.
This.
Swiss region may soon beat Hong Kong as best company tax Haven,
Hong Kong will soon lose its status as the place with the world's lowest
corporate tax replaced by the small mountainous,
Ken of Nidwalden in Switzerland, Bloomberg.
Excellent is currently carrying out one of the most significant tax reforms in
decades.
Many cantons are drastically reducing the tax burden on corporate profits to
attract more investment and encourage business growth.
Of course the country also has some problems, but.
Lucky problems.
Is that the strategy followed by the central bankers around so much interest
that some academics are already wondering whether it would not be appropriate
for the Swiss government to take advantage of its ability to finance itself at
negative rates to issue large amounts of debt and use this money to create its
own sovereign fund. Anyway,
as we said at the beginning in matters of skiing and money,
it's best not to mess with the Swiss.
In a nutshell, my friends,
this is the amazing story of the most unusual central bank in the world. Now,
if you've found this video that we've prepared in collaboration value score,
interesting.
Don't forget to click on the like button and subscribe to visual politics.
Take care. I'll see you next time.
[Inaudible].